herzlich willkommen zur heutigen sitzung
in der wir uns mit einer neuen position
befassen werden im spektrum der
freiheits thematik nämlich mit diesem
herrn hier mit robert kane und robert
cain ist ein ganz führender vertreter
einer position die man entweder lieber
tourismus nimmt oder vegetarismus
stimmt's marco wie soll ich es hin
schreiben lieber terrorismus oder
liberta realismus das problem bei
liebherr tourismus ist das lieber
tourismus auch eine politische position
ist deswegen hat sommer schreiben hat
das schreiben einen liebert ariana oder
die batterie marco du darfst
hinschreiben also wenn wir können
letztendlich sagen die batterie oder die
batterie libertarian und dann liefert
aris muss oder die beta realismus
häufig wird eben lieber zahl im sinne
der politischen philosophie verwendet
wenn es eben um sehr freiheits affine
position geht und das ist damit nicht
gemeint
und jetzt erklärt damm erklärst du mal
marco was es damit auf sich hat wir
haben ein letztes werden jetzt in den
letzten sekunden ist mehr ein punkt
leben gesprochen
man kann eigentlich den robert kurzmann
hast das problem der freiheit des
bieterverfahren
und das ist ja eben lässt dass wir
heimlich die überzeugung haben dass wir
zumindest manchmal zwischen echten
alternativen wären also wieder einmal in
seinem leben kinder haben werden oder
nicht
wir denken geben dies liegt daran dass
entscheiden natürlich müssen wir noch
die richtigen umstände gegeben sein aber
wir haben eine echte wahl
das problem ist es gibt ziemlich gute
philosophische argumente die zeigen was
du dir die praxen war und zwar können
uns vorstellen ich muss mich zwischen
zwei tiefen entscheiden kinder bekommen
nicht und es gibt eigentlich logisch
gesehen und zwei ndr ist meine
entscheidung
die termin- oder es ist nicht die
technik dann wird es nicht das einzige
mal wenn sie wie terminiert ist
anscheinend schon im vorhinein fest geht
um zu sagen wie ich mich entscheide
sodann habe ich keine echte war keine
echte alternative
da musste ich mich so entscheidungen
oder ist nicht zu terminieren dann
scheint die ganze sache eine
entscheidung ein produkt des zufalls zu
sein
wahrscheinlich irgendwie keine kontrolle
über den hausgang meine entscheidung zu
haben
also das ist es
oder determinismus und in der tabelle
sind die größeren und dank deswegen die
sogenannten wie die kompatibel ist das
etwas kompatibles bedeutet dass die
kompatibel ist glaubten dass
determinismus mit echter wahlrecht
entscheidung und ich habe kurz eine
frage markus schön wenn ich unterbreche
du hattest gesagt also kompatibel ist
muss bedeutet dass freiheit mit der
termin ismus vereinbar ist könnte man
nicht auch sagen es gibt eine form von
kompatibel ist muss die sagt freiheit
ist mit in determinismus kompatibel aber
nicht mit determinismus weil bisher ist
es ja immer so kompatibel ist sagt der
in determinismus es falsch und daraus
folgt dann irgendwie dass der
determinismus zusammen mit der freiheit
bestehen genau könnte es nicht auch ein
kompatibles muss geben der sagt freiheit
ist nur mit in die tenders gibt solche
positionen
gibt es und robert payne wird natürlich
eine sein
der name wird nämlich dafür verwendet
das tatsächlich sind hat rheinische
gründen weil man halt ist also in der
geschichte hauptsächlich es wieder auf
das problem fokussiert msb vereinfachung
und dann an sich einfach dem dieser name
herauskristallisiert also komm
pessimismus curie gesagt dass ihn
zusammenhalt das zusammen das ist
vereinfacht
aber es stimmt natürlich da gibt es
leute die heute gerät er würde sagen ne
feine termin ismus des passenden
zusammen dass es ihm kompatibel
kompatibles muss alles immer mit bezug
auf determinismus und nicht mit bezug
auf in der termin kann auch damit
zusammenhängen dass eben determinismus
der grundbegriff ist und in
determinismus immer nur das negiert dh
determinismus ist prominent in form des
bezugs
zu müssen eine ganze zeit lang haben die
wissenschaftler glauben dass unser
system klarerweise termin ist ist also
wer also der ganzen zeit ermöglichen
nach wissenschaftlichen weltbildes
monate jedes irgendwie offensichtlich
zur seite deswegen mal dass das auto weg
und jetzt hat sich das alles und schwarz
ist er natürlich gewandelt es gibt eher
ein zeichen zu sagen und das universum
in dem wir leben ist nicht depressiv
deswegen sitzt man hat sich der focus
ein bisschen verlagert aber die
technologie ist noch inhalt also das ist
das problem
meine entscheidung scheint nicht eine
echte entscheidung zu sein wenn man
entscheidungen terminiert ist
das sagen wir kompatibel ist und das hat
dort ein penner und das klassische
argument aufhörst zu sagen wenn ich ja
meine entscheidung an meiner zukünftigen
etwas ändern
achtet dann müsste ich bin
diese schreiben
umgesetzt ist müsste ich entweder die
naturgesetze habe ich es kann und ich
kann natürlich nicht an den
naturgesetzen irgendetwas ändern wer
kann also kann ich auch nichts an meiner
zukünftigen das ist es so genannte
konsequenz argument und damit kenne das
hat der position vertreten er sagte ja
also dieses konsequenz argument ist
nicht so können wir dieses konsequenz
argument mal kurz formalisieren als ich
schreibe es mal hin und konsequenz
argument konsequenz da steht natürlich
die folge drin die sequenz sieg wie
lateinisch folgen wir haben eine
konjunktion aus prämisse könnte man das
sagen du hattest glaube sagt p 0 oder
was ist das machst du das mal erklärst
du mal wie das also wie dieses dieses
konsequenz kann man einfach dahin
vielleicht hin schreibt also für die
ihren erfahrungen teilhaben ließ er
daran geschrieben also man sagt man
normalerweise nun ist einfach eine
beschreibung nicht gegangen also
vorstellt mal folien hat die scharfen
worten
verloren umso weiter sofort auflistung
von taktischen die ganze verpackt
unter den hammer endlich die auflistung
aller
also passt auf
3 satz 1 nummer und wir nehmen das in
konjunktion vor beiden also die
beschreibung der vergangenheit in der
beschreibung der naturgesetze und wände
determinismus war es dann voll und aus
dieser aus diesen beiden sammlung
erfolgt jede beliebige wartet also jeder
beliebige andere zustand könnte man
nicht auch sagen p 0 ist ein bestimmter
beliebiger zustand der vergangenheit
weil wenn wir einmal den zustand
fixieren ja und die gesetze haben können
wir daraus eigentlich alles erklären
genauso ist also ein beliebiger sagen
die welt eingefroren eine beliebige welt
es gibt jetzt halt nur dieses könnte
aber eine mögliche andere welt geben
aber einen schnappschuss der welt wo
alles ist und daneben noch die gesetze
dazu die das dann determinieren und
daraus folgt dann mit dem index könnte
man auch sagen zeitlich also p 0 und
dann hier vielleicht ppb 0 und dann hier
ptx oder suchen
dass man sagt also ein intelligenter
werbung wenn er vollstes wissen über den
zustand des universums einem beliebigen
zeitpunkt hat und wenn er alle gesetze
kennt diesen bisschen keine flüchtigen
zu stellen ist und wie es vorher war
und das ist die grundidee des feminismus
also finger weg und dann sagen wir dazu
na ja gut ist unabänderlich wir können
an der vergangenheit nichts ändern wenn
es schon unabänderlich wir können nichts
an den naturgesetzen ende also bis auf
pink und wir können nichts dafür können
sie bis zum beispiel möglich wäre
entwürfe entscheiden dass ich keine
kinder habe und da können sie doch
nichts wert also ist das konsequenz im
moment kennt sagt und dann haben wir
gegründet 25 diesem argument
anbringen und zwar deswegen weil die
sagen wir natürlich immer mit dem
begriff können auch und kein vater
gewesen
der begriff können wird man also bild
vom komponisten anders verstanden und
komponistin die sagen ein bisschen
problematisch akzeptiert ist im moment
aber er versteht dass auch mit dem
listen sich dadurch uns überzeugt also
deswegen sagt klein machen
2 für freiheit brauchen wir nicht nur
anders anderen können dass ente diesem
prinzip der alternative möglichkeit oder
alternativ service abgeben
wir brauchen wir ein etwas anderes wir
brauchen un inhalte mit responsibility
letztes beamten
wir müssen die letzte verantwortung für
uns entscheiden wir müssen nicht nur
wenn wir uns fällt es entscheidung auf
anders entscheiden können wenn ich mich
dafür studium zu ende zu bringen
und wenn es eine freie entscheidung ist
dann muss auch
nach rechts auf die letzte verantwortung
für die es im schatten tagen sagen
kennen und das war ganz anderes als dass
ich verantwortlich bin für alle
zugreifen gegründete mannschaften haben
also es darf nicht irgendwelche ursachen
geben für dich nicht mehr verantwortung
habe ursache gegen mich zu dieser
entscheidung geführt haben als sagen wir
mal ich im moment so viele zu ende aber
den einzigen philosophie schirm zu ende
bringen ist mein angst vor meinem vater
wird
wenn jetzt füllen die angst um meine
haare nicht verantwortlich bin dann bin
ich intuitiv auch nicht wirklich
verantwortung dafür dass ich meine
philosophie
deswegen sagt training wir müssen
letztverantwortung seien für unseren
schatten
das ist so wie dieser grund wer meint
das ist ein neues argument für den
informatiker
deswegen ist also der liberalismus
besteht dass zwei sollen die gäste ist
in kommunismus freiheit und die termine
zahl weit und realismus gehen nicht
zusammen aber freiheit und in
determinismus arbeit im determinismus
gehen zusammen warum bei wir doch
offensichtlich frei also das ist die
zweite säule des liberalismus mit dem
meniskus nicht zusammen aber wir sind
trotzdem frei also sendetermin ismus
falsch also das ende termin ismus waren
das ist die große schwierigkeit von über
terrorismus
wie passend freiheit und entwicklung
zusammen wie könnte plausibel machen
dass wenn meine entscheidung nicht
dass sie damit kein produkt des zufalls
sondern immer noch etwas ist was ich
selbst bestimmt letztverantwortlich
vollziehen und das ist ein so der der
hauptfokus im osten wie kriegen wir das
zusammen können wir obwohl wir natürlich
mit den determinismus haben plausibel
machen dass es trotzdem ein
entscheidendes also will ich auch so
dass grundsätzlich und dann ganz anders
ein paar nebenkriegsschauplätze dafür
dass eine ist agenten großereignis
kausalität genau das hatten wir auch
schon ganz kurz besprochen ja also woher
kommen einfach die kausalkette die
dominierende kraft kommt die aus der
natur aus den naturgesetzen oder kommt
dieses kausale aus uns selbst und zwar
so dass es einen spontanen anfang hat
das ist also eine art von unbewegten
beweger ist das etwas plötzlich entsteht
und eigentlich keine vorhergehenden
ursachen hat dies bewirkt sein dass der
grund einfachen uns selbst liegt das
dann so eine art von akteurs kausalität
und dann stellt sich die frage wie sich
akteurs kausale ereignisse mit natur
causa und ereignissen verhalten
zueinander also ob dann sondern die
natur kausalität durch die ereignisse
kausalität verdrängt wird oder ob sie
nur ergänzt wird
ob sie dadurch fundiert wird also die
frage ist wenn man von mehreren formen
von kausalität spricht wie sich diese
form von qualität zusammen verhalten das
ist ein riesenproblem
das cave also kein anderer dem anspruch
erwünscht ein wissenschaftliches
reflektierten das heißt wenn ich etwas
machen was eigentlich wirklich mit
unseren besten wissenschaftlichen
theorien den sandkasten und danach das
was die meisten diebe teilen wir bis
jetzt gemacht haben ist etwas was einige
wirklich gut mit unserem besten
wissenschaftlichen theorien zusammen
also die die post zu leben dann
irgendwelche komischen entitäten die
dann irgendwie ganz frei von alter und
eine kausalität dann irgendwie so groben
schweben und dann so oft und so
eingreifen wenn seine haben nach ist es
etwas mysteriöses da können wir nicht
ernsthaft wissenschaftlich damit
arbeiten sein anspruch ist etwas zu
entwickeln was man eben auch einen
naturwissenschaftler verkaufen kann
genau und deswegen haben wir jetzt hier
diese leitfragen also welche bedeutung
spielt für robert caine der in
determinismus haben wir schon ein
bisschen behandelt was versteht kein
unters l-form injuries das ist ein ganz
wichtiger begriff für diejenigen von
ihnen die bei dem workshop mit peter von
in welchen dabei waren ist dieser
begriff bekannt weil eine der
teilnehmerinnen dieses konzept zur
sprache gebracht hat inwiefern kann kane
zwischen angekommen und an kost
unterscheiden was ist ein korse linde
termin ist also darauf läuft das ganze
dann hinaus also in determinismus
dadurch können wir eben den
kompatibilität minder determinismus
falsch ist und der ist dann aber kausal
zu denken und über diesen kausalen im
determinismus versucht keine bestimmte
form von determiniert haid durch die
hintertüre wieder ins spiel zu bringen
scheint mir da durch den begriff der
kausalität und sagt also auch wenn etwas
in determiniert ist heißt es nicht dass
es keine ursache hätte also
ursächlichkeit ist nicht mit der
terminiert hat offensichtlich gleich zu
sehen
nachdem das ist ganz wichtig um platz
gut machen zu können dass es muss nicht
gleich die meist sehr sehr schweres
forderung deutschland eine ganz
komplizierte begriffsgeschichte und
gerade in eine wichtige bedeutung für
unzuverlässig grund grund unserer zeit
genug gäste danken mehr trinkt sagt
sätze wie im getränk einen termin ist im
prozess waren eine interministerielle
entscheidung
und das führt mich zu einem weiteren
punkt ich halte mich nämlich vorhin
gefragt ist das eine ausschließliche
alternative also verhalten sich
determinismus und in determinismus
kontradiktorisch zueinander oder nur
konträr
also lassen sie noch eine dritte oder
vierte fünfte alternative offen
offensichtlich sowie keine sieht nämlich
er sagt es gibt hier noch zu fall der
nicht mit dem der termin ist
gleichzusetzen ist wie ich es mir nicht
recht verstehen würde also sagen
zufall ist falsch verträgt sich nicht
mit freiheit determinismus ist falsch
aber in determinismus verträgt sich mit
freiheit weil im determinismus mit
kausaler strukturiertheit kompatible
denkmals würde zudem zu stimmen oder
also ist genau determinismus mit zu
vernehmen und in den terrorismus ohne
schufa oder er versteht dass tatsächlich
noch als der dritte als ein thema wurde
er vom indie termin ist aber der text
gibt es nicht her weil er ja gar nicht
miteinander ist das gemerkt haben an dem
tag beginnt mit definitionen und
arbeiten sehr homogen sportplatz erteilt
habe intuitiv und ergänzt also ich
glaube mich zu erinnern dass er so klare
definition in diesem text jedenfalls
sicher hat ja viele texte verfasst auch
ein buch und so ich glaube es geht in
manchen texten noch ein bisschen
logischer zu aber er hat mir deswegen so
gut gefallen wir haben auch diesen text
deswegen gewählt weil er ebenso
interessante beispiele gewählt hat jetzt
eben sehr so wie du sagst ist eben sehr
nahe an zur lebenswirklichkeit
auch der text von von ihnen wegen den
wir ja gelesen hatten in der letzten
sitzung der war ja auch nicht
formalisiert von ihm wegen daneben auch
text hat mir alles nur formalisiert gibt
es auch
ich habe mir gefällt ihr dann dass
andere besser ist doch wunderbar dass
wir uns so ergänzen das ist eine frage
dann wie verhält sich keynes theorie zu
gegenwärtigen physik das ist also auch
noch ein wichtiger punkt generell für
alle freiheits theorien was wir auch
schon bei immanuel kant sehen eine
überzeugende freiheits theorie muss
zeigen wie freiheit mit den
erkenntnissen der modernen
naturwissenschaft vereinbar ist wie sie
damit zusammenhängt wie freiheit in das
moderne weltbild aus einer
physikalischen journalistischer sicht
passt immanuel kant sagt das sagt uns
ganz genau wie wir uns beides zusammen
vorstellen können und eben auch wird
kane sagt dass weitere frage haben wir
erst mal nicht und dann können wir
einfach jemand beginnen also er bringt
selbst jetzt hier mal so viele fragen
die er selbst auf hilft also ist die
antwort wird sein 1 2 do you want it
warum wollen wir überhaupt freiheit so
lese ich das vermissen also
die frage der freiheit überhaupt
bestimmte phänomene erklären das
wichtigste zu moralischen bis 15 meter
tiefer hat deshalb in unseren
zwischenmenschlichen beziehungen wie man
die anderen dafür verantwortlich für das
was sie getan haben die moralische
vorbereitung gesagt das hättest du nicht
machen soll
und so weiter und so fort also diese
ganze zuschreibung moralische
verantwortung bis etwas was uns sehr
wichtig ist es unsere menschen in
russland
ich habe meinen gedanken leben zu
resignation freiheit da gab es einen
studenten in der tat geleugnet hat das
in moralische verantwortung wichtig sein
meinte er würde niemals im leben die man
sagen etwas ab und sorge für mich und er
hält es auch für völlig inklusive war
weil er bestimmte physikalische theorien
vorhält und wenn du glaubtest in
freiheit mit zu landen war ganz simpel
sein neuester sagen wenn ist
normalerweise und die meisten schulen
nahmen über zugestimmt
ist es eine sache die uns enorm also
wenn uns wenn wir in eine
kz-gedenkstätte und uns anschauen was da
gemacht wurde dann ist es uns enorm
wichtig zu sagen dass die menschen die
dafür verantwortlich sind und wir haben
heute auch eine vorhand
um so etwas zu verhindern also ist es
etwas wirklich basis und grund wichtig
ist für unser zusammenleben
ja uns die frage ist natürlich brauchen
wir wirklich frei das ist die frage über
freizeit internetbrowser verwirklichte
entscheidungsalternativen um diese um
diese praxis der zuschreibung moralische
verantwortung zu rechtfertigen oder
nicht und nein wir brauchen das nichts
und ken versucht sich also bei dieser
zwei tage in diesem hinblick zu
positionieren
also der welt ihr dann auch so ein
bisschen sagen wir ja für den begriff
der verantwortung wir dann ganz zentral
auch für seinen freiheitsverständnis
verwenden und das hat ja auch
letztendlich also also hätte spannende
fragen also ich seh ist schon so weil er
dreht wir davon dass wir über
determiniert sind auch wenn wir keine
alternativen möglichkeiten faktisch
haben aber diese zusätzliche terminiert
haid die eben verhindert dass das fehlen
von alternativen möglichkeiten uns
unfall macht die interpretiere ich so
dass das eben der anker ist der
zurechenbarkeit determination aber das
ist ein weiterer punkt vielleicht ein
ergänzender punkt unabhängig davon ob
wir jetzt so was im organischen
zurechenbarkeit vertreten oder sie für
sinnvoll erachten als individuen werden
wir davon immer betroffen sein weil
unser sozialsystem hier und eigentlich
überall auf der welt so funktioniert das
wenn wir irgendwas tun was unmoralisch
erscheint sanktioniert werden
wir mögen der meinung seien es ist nicht
wichtig aber wir werden eben dann die
konsequenzen spüren müssen das kann
jetzt natürlich kein richtiges argument
sein dafür dass es das gibt aber
lebensweltlich gesprochen ist dieses
prinzip so wichtig dass wir uns fast gar
keine gesellschaft vorstellen können
indem man davon ausgeht dass dieses
prinzip der zurechenbarkeit oder der
urheberschaft auch nicht anwendung
finden
[Musik]
dritten these dass das wünschen frei
sind dass wir keine bedenken haben also
das ist keinen ausweg gibt ein problem
ist eben gelernt hat und dass freiheit
aber notwendig ist moralische
verantwortung und das wird es auch nicht
geben
er ist ein ganz berühmter und der würde
gesagt weckten dient dafür dass wir
unser unser unsere ganze gesellschaft
neu formieren neuform gehen und unser
ganzes verständnis und revolutionären zu
mir und dessen hier eigentlich
sanktionen und sprachdaten ganz anders
verstehen als wesentliches heute
verstehen sondern es gibt mehr darauf
dass wir die menschen prävention
aber es geht nicht wirklich da also wir
sollten nicht denken dass diese menschen
wirklich war
[Musik]
es betrifft uns wirklich selbst ganz
konkret dann fragt er weiter kein remake
termin ist also die frage gerade wenn
wir jetzt hier sagen wir haben hier eine
form von ihm kompatibel ist muss also
determinismus ist falsch können wir dann
angesichts dessen was dann noch übrig
bleibt sei es zufall oder in der termin
ist muss oder nur in der termin ismus
mit verschiedenen formen der ausprägung
können wir dann auf basis eines eines
komplexen eines verfeinerten vor einer
verfeinerten form von indie termin ist
muss dann noch von freiheit sprechen und
dann eben am ende die frage die wir auch
schon gestellt haben wie es mit
naturwissenschaftlichen erkenntnissen
und auch sozial wissenschaftlichen
erkenntnissen verträglich ist ein so
verstandener frey wille der eben nicht
mit dem determinismus
kompatibles können wir dennoch in unser
weltbild einpassen und so weltbild was
natürlich naturwissenschaftlich und
sozialwissenschaftlich bestimmt ist das
ist die frage
und jetzt kommt hier diese jetzt kommen
wir diese verschiedenen bedingungen die
es jetzt gibt es hier schon mal in
diesem in dieser kurzen passage gibt es
jetzt hier schon ein paar wichtige
begriffe nämlich chaos und motiv das
sind ja ganz wichtige begriffe die man
auch in dem kontext eines kausalen in
determinismus eine rolle spielen
anzuwenden das in form gebracht hatte
also wenn ich meine philosophie studium
beenden
aus angst um mein vater dann bin ich nur
damit verantwortlich für spenden und
wenn ihr auch verantwortung dafür wenn
wir sind einfach das heißt wenn ich
sagen kann wirklich anders hingegen tun
dass ich ein zu kommen konnte liegt das
dem leben gegriffen scheint nicht
verantworten
es ist vielleicht ein beispiel ich denke
guten gedanken schon klar
also wenn wir wenn wir die vorlesungen
verpassen weil es ein recht bahnchaos in
münchen gibt und wenn der professor zu
uns kommen sagt wie konnten sie diese
vorlesung verpassen
sie fallen jetzt durch weil sie müssen
der anwesenheitspflicht und ich weiß
wenn sie diesen professor glaubhaft
machen können dass der zu reichen
die ursache dafür dass sie die forderung
nicht besucht haben
die ist das s-bahn-chaos münchen gab und
wenn sie auch plausibel machen können
dass sie nicht dafür verantwortlich sind
dass es im s-bahn-chaos in münchen
gehabt dann sind sie auch nicht dafür
verantwortlich dass ich vorne sind also
das ist der grundgedanke sie müssen für
alle hinreichend
hier werden schreiben verantwortung sein
[Musik]
und jetzt stellt es gibt diese frage wie
diese gründe und motive die eben für
diese zurechenbarkeit notwendig sondern
vorausgesetzt werden müssen wie die sich
zum prinzip des determinismus verhalten
und an naheliegender schluss wäre ja zu
sagen alle gründe alle motive alle
bedingungen die sowas wie ultimative
zurechenbarkeit konstituieren oder
möglich machen oder wie auch immer
bedingt die sind nur so denkbar dass wir
sie als determiniert faktoren erzählen
und das würde ja jetzt kein wohl nicht
wollen diese ultimative zurechenbarkeit
in die tennis muss diesen kursen in die
termin ist entwickeln das ist ja so sein
ziel und da er will ja formen von
kausalität offensichtlich verteidigen
die nicht deterministisch aber haben die
motive haben die motive dadurch also es
gibt motive können wir offensichtlich
nicht mit determinismus würde eher sagen
richtig erklären offensichtlich kann man
noch ein bisschen schauen vielleicht im
folgenden
ich fand es halt interessant hier konnte
ist schön kantischen chaos und not also
der begriff das eines motivs
als beweggrund der ist eigentlich so im
allgemeinen sprachgebrauch jedenfalls
einig inkompatibel mit starke form von
terrorismus oder
das motiv im grund steckt schon
enthalten dass er meiner freiheit
zugänglich ist so dass es sich aus
freiheit verdankt und ja also so wie der
löwe ist man auch schon weil also ich
denke der gedanke was wäre also motive
sind gestern motive wenn es wirklich
eine rolle spielen wenn die motive
stehen dann spielen ja offensichtlich
nur physikalische oder so genau gründen
ursachen so dieses doppelte er spricht
hier von crysis und auch bzw oder das
könnte jetzt auch eine art von identität
sein das müssen wir noch offen lassen
ich glaube genau das restliche er will
nur sagen wenn wir eine absicht haben
nicht verantwortlich sind und wenn diese
absicht zugleich bewohnt von unserer
handlung ist dann sind wir auch schon
sagen
aber natürlich ist es so gerade bei den
absichten ist es müsse mit komische
sache wenn ich jetzt sage ich habe die
nachbarin umgebracht weil elke haben
wollte also aufgrund der absicht geld zu
nehmen
also kann ich nichts dafür das ist jetzt
angesagt das wäre seltsam sagte stone
begrifflicher widerspruch absichten
scheint irgendwie begrifflich schon
etwas zu sein
die genaue rolle habe ich natürlich sind
wir verantwortlich
unsere absicht also also das finde ich
interessant der punkt wo wir ansetzen
können leser mal weitere haben sie noch
selbst ein punkt dazu vielleicht müssen
noch ein bisschen weiter lesen um noch
ein bisschen mehr stoppen
zu haben die smartphones sollen dies
formuliert charges racing wird kennt mir
libyen termin ist und turns dhfk to
various obscure eines tieres mysteriums
of agency obsession to make up the
difference jetzt kommt ein philosoph den
wir in einer der nächsten sitzung noch
behandelt werden und country weekend
explain früher in scientific sessions
folge lief in realität zu account for i
have to appear to the agency of what he
called on human space marines
respektables continue to believe that
only some sort of human body die listen
can make sense of science in the
terminal place for steps as call center
for the conservation agency nation
so jetzt hat er hier als die position
der agenten kausalität eigentlich noch
thematisiert
jedenfalls so eine ganz starke form von
libertarian ist könnte man das nicht
sagen
also von nominalen
selbst hier spricht sie davon
hier in diesem oberen teil das wäre also
so was was bei kant keeper emanuel kant
wir kommen darauf noch zu sprechen
eine nominale selbst es ist also eine
entität die irgendwie jenseits des
physikalisch determinierten
zusammenhangs existiert und von dort
irgendwie was in die welt entsendet na
ja so dass dieser diese option muss ist
iris forms of agency ist es konsequent
zeit unterstützen
falsche leben aber die mischung kann es
eben etwas ganz kurz aus dem ausland
brauchen zeit ist weil ich noch nie
vorher was eigentlich medien und in
diesem sinn brandy champion zu sein die
große schwierigkeiten erkannt einfach
ähnlich und gedanken zu erklären wie
diese bei ebene überhaupt zusammen
spielen können wie kann man von einem
standpunkt außerhalb von raum und zeit
wirkungen im raum und zeit hervorrufen
das ist das große problem ist dass man
dabei kennt hat oder sowieso was machen
wir mit den naturwissenschaften wenn die
doch eigentlich annehmen dass alles in
raum und zeit ist genauso zumindest
erklärt werden angenommen
und wenn diese dieses tanz empirische
kraftzentrum hier
wenn das eben trans empirisch ist dann
impliziert dass dass es nicht durch die
naturwissenschaften erklärt werden kann
weil naturwissenschaften nur empirisch
dinge analysieren können und daraus
würde dann wiederum so eine art von
mysterien ismus folgen jetzt andere art
als bei den wagen das ist einfach ein
gewisses phänomen nicht angemessen
erklären können mit
naturwissenschaftlichen methoden
eine meinung zu fügen also man sollte
natürlich auch was zu sagen dass das
jetzt nicht mit den wissenschaften
selbst sollte aufpassen also kann sagte
es ist vereinbar
interessant ist die wissenschaft selbst
gesagt in köln hat es
naturwissenschaftlich erklären sondern
es ist ein postulat bis viele
wissenschaftler aufstellen
die motivation ist unerklärbar aber es
ist nicht so dass irgendwie
wissenschaftlich bewiesen hat dass wir
alles in wissenschaftlich erklären
natürlich nicht es gibt sogar gute
gründe anzunehmen dass es unmöglich ist
als er was er sagen will es die frage
ist brauchen wir solche starken solche
schlag anderen baumarten wenn wir sie
nicht brauchen
dann sollten wir diese sache nicht als
dessen nicht so wichtig dass jedes motiv
ich würde nicht mehr nur vorsichtig zu
sagen dass so ein bild ist völlig
unvereinbar mit der natur
die man im begriff des transrapids liegt
eben das ist halt nicht zugänglich ist
richtig richtig aber er möchte ebenso
ein bisschen versuchen auch das mit den
naturwissenschaften iss zu bringen
das ist so sein punkten also er ist ja
schon lieber paris die batterien ist und
ihr kritisch ein da aber so ein bisschen
die batterien müssten zu kritisieren so
ein bisschen also die tatsache dass er
so starke form von agenten kausalität
die so müsst ihr mysteriösen anschein
erwecken oder so nominale selbst
kritisiert was eigentlich häufig so was
ist was auch lieber tahrir- annehmen
riskant auf dem noch kommen die batterie
oder nichtsein kompakt ist ganz
schwierige frage
er ist kompatibel ist aber in einem ganz
anderen sinne von kompatibel ist als wir
es heute sagen würden
man kann auch als die batterie
bezeichnen kann in einer gewissen weise
also die tatsache dass die batterie
manchmal so problematisch annahmen
machen wie nominale selbst oder trans
empirische kraftzentren heißt nicht dass
die libertarian ismus falsch sein muss
das will ja auch eine form davon
schon allein dadurch definiert dass mit
dem inkompatibel ist muss und durch die
annahme der freiheit also ändert aber
unterscheidet sich von anderen portalen
dadurch dass er versucht die sache ein
bisschen verträglicher oder currenta mit
den wissenschaften und theologisch
sparsamer vor allem ja und das ist
motive sich auf alle fälle
zurzeit bauen
die entscheidung
[Musik]
das ist man muss da das ist ein guter
punkt man muss unterscheiden zwei formen
des ichs balkan es gibt es
transzendentale ich auf das haben sie
jetzt zu recht hingewiesen und dann gibt
es eben doch noch das nominale ich das
tanz zentrale ich es rein formal das
wäre unter logisch kein problem das ist
die bedingung der möglichkeit des
zusammenhangs unserer ganzen erfahrung
aber dann gibt es eben noch in
praktischer hinsicht eine kritik der
praktischen vernunft so was wie ein
nominales selbst und das
ja und dieses ja und dieses nominale
selbst wenn ich ihn recht verstehe hat
nicht nur diese einheits stiftende
funktion sondern nahles selbst ist ist
sein grund einer bestimmten art von
kausalität die kausalität aus freiheit
und freiheitskampf qualität und da
scheint mir das kann dir ein trans
zentrale rede von bedingungen der
möglichkeiten etwas übersteigt und doch
ziemlich starke ja und logische annahmen
macht wenn er von kausalität spricht
dann haben wir es hier nicht mehr nur
mit bedingungen die möglichkeit etwas zu
tun haben es mit faktischen wirksamen
entitäten zu tun wo er von kraft von von
qualität spricht und insofern kann man
kann das durchaus ein bisschen vorwerfen
dass er da auch wenn er jetzt kein
richtiger und theologe ist kann ist ein
trans en tal verlosen die rede von einem
nominalen selbst klingt schon sehr sehr
unter logisch im gegensatz zu
transzendieren selbst
[Musik]
ja genau also dieses nominale selbst
hängt mit kants begriff der vernunft
zusammen die wiederum von dem vermögen
des verstandes unterschieden werden muss
und wir kommen da auch noch ausführlich
darauf zu sprechen aber ist eine
wichtige frage wie diese ich zu
verstehen müssen
[Musik]
auch weil
und markiert also dem mädchen geworden
ein paar
diese möglichkeit
der dreier spieler
vielleicht kommen die entscheidung
mal dass ich mir
vorstellen könnte ich
eine möglichkeit
ja also dabei wird kenne natürlich noch
nichts da muss man die definition genau
am nächsten war der sagt jetzt frischen
fuest das ist dann das entscheidung wenn
sie wirklich die möglichkeit haben diese
ursache zu umgehen ist es teil
hinzuweisen kann die zurechnung kommt
wenn sie die möglichkeit haben
trotz der anwesenheit für sehr gute
sache auch anders zu erkunden und dann
würde sein prinzip auch nicht kalt dass
wenn es nur eine von vielen ursachen ist
also eine ursache auf eine abweichung im
ergebnis an dann würde dieses prinzip in
vergleichenden verantworten müssen
natürlich entscheiden das ist ein
wichtiger punkt weil natürlich ist
irgendwie auch die tatsache dass vor
jahrmillionen von japan ein komet die
erde verfehlt hat es irgendwie eben eine
von vielen ursachen dafür dass wir heute
hier stehen und reden kann wenn der
kommentare getroffen hätte und jetzt
schon sagen
aber natürlich ist niemand dafür
verantwortlich dass der komiker verfehlt
haben trotzdem würde niemand von uns
sagen diese tatsache ist schon in
reichen himmel hat eine grund anzunehmen
dass niemand uns irgendwas anderes
wissen weil das ist nur eine von vielen
ursachen aber es ist keine welt wird es
das gerücht
und genau so lange kämpfen dass wenn sie
dann sagen okay mein fall ist es so
jedenfalls also wenn jetzt jemand
einst wurden vater hat dabei irgendwie
die möglichkeit hat durch psychologische
tricks die sache zu umgehen
dann wären die angst vor dem vater nicht
hinreichender grund zu behalten
und dann dann kann man das prinzip von
kay noch nicht an
bei canon gibt es solche freiräume für
kreativität der kommen noch drauf also
sein sohn im determinismus wie er ihn
versteht der liefert schon glaube ich
spiel also freiraum für sowas wie
kreativität also ich glaube dass das
sehr anschlussfeld ist diese reflektiert
der begriff von in determinismus die
nato aber das müssen wir jetzt einfach
nur mal schauen also hier geht es jetzt
erstmal so um so eine abgrenzung von
otto logisch sehr anspruchsvollen
theorien von lieber tag ist die
katholischen positionen und jetzt ist
als seine bezeichnung icx familien
strategies for making sense of review
extra fekter die bhf cindy sherman ist
europa mit weight watchers oder extrakte
france agency of the flow of events to
go away
vielleicht könnten wir mal das erst mal
nur bis dahin behandeln also jetzt hat
er hier eine klassifikation diese form
von liebert arian ist man die er die
extra faktor theorien nennt also wir
brauchen so ein zusätzlicher faktor der
uns an determinismus zum/zur
bestimmtheit bringt also wir haben
erstmal so unentschiedenheit im in der
termin ist muss weil der termin ist es
falsch ist und wir können in diesem
entschiedenen zustand nicht bleiben
also muss was von außen oder so hinzu
kommen ja also wie kann ich glauben
machen dass diese entscheidung kein
produkt des zufalls ist genug einfach so
wie wenn ich jetzt eine günstige wolf
genannt was geht dann eben mal gesagt na
gut der unterschied zwischen dieser
entscheidung ein münzwurf ist dass diese
entscheidung durch mich da wohl sagt
dass durch ein agent oder durch einen
raum zeit mich durch einen geistigen
agenten außerhalb von raum und zeit und
so gibt es verschiedene versionen dieser
art waren extra factor starten aber ja
selber okay bis das sehr skeptisch er
ist skeptisch dass so was wirklich nötig
ist um zu erklären dass unsere
entscheidung kein produkt des zufalls
desto mehr wird es anders versuchen
genau
als es so wenn der termin ismus wahr ist
dann ist der determinismus falsch jetzt
im engeren sinne
und dann heißt das dass wir auf
natürliche ebene lebensweltliche ebene
jedenfalls eigentlich keine richtigen
gründe angeben können für unser handeln
wir müssen das aber tun und deswegen
muss etwas von außerhalb der natur
kommen die als intendiert angesehen wird
und das will er jetzt eben
problematisieren also das ist jetzt eine
form von liebert aris muss dir nicht mag
und von der er sagt dass sie weitere
mysterien mit sich führen würde und
darin steht damit von den wagen über ein
der auch ein kritiker der liberianischen
positionen ist und er möchte jetzt also
have to strike out new directions
holding aps zu extra fekter strategies
alte gelder including special forces of
aging position
ok und jetzt müssen uns fragen wie
beschreibt er diese neuen wege um diese
problematik dieser extra faktoren diese
außerhalb befindlichen entität 'neben zu
vermeiden
und jetzt und jetzt gibt es praktische
zustand den er sich überlegt das ist
wenn wir jetzt uns mal diesen
integrierten zustand vorstellen wollen
er hat er so gedankenexperimente und er
spricht davon dass wir eigentlich dann
in so eine art von spannung uns befinden
also wir könnten tun könnten nicht tun
das könnte jetzt b sein als er bringt
diese diesen determiniert heitz zustand
auf so eine ausschließliche alternative
zurück autonome oder b&b es nun a und 10
b
letztendlich und das ist ein zustand in
dem wir uns sagt er in einer wirklichen
entscheidungssituation befinden müssen
und aus diesem aus diesem indifferenz
zustand der nicht eine bloße
willkürliches zufalls zustand ist dann
der eben schon in sich eine spannung hat
und das ist jetzt eben gerade punkt aus
dieser spannung heraus können wir die
freie entscheidung nach kane erklären
ohne extra faktoren zusätzliche faktoren
mit hinein zu nehmen ich glaube das sind
jetzt ist der punkt ist so vor wie ein
search engine attention wie viel soul
searching moments of self
ist das reflektiert in die termine von
eurosystems experience internally
uncertainty and response physically to
the opening of the window of opportunity
der temporarily screens auf komplette
termination bei influence of the past
also er sagt es gibt bestimmte
situationen das sind also ganz
grundlegende situationen des sind soul
searching moments als existenzielle
situation in denen wir unsere weitere
zukunft bestimmen müssen also jetzt
nicht schokoladeneis oder himbeereis
oder schokoladen als und nicht
schokoladeneis müsste man genau genommen
sagen weil schokoladeneis hinter als
erdbeereis und so weiter wenn sie zu
verrückten 1 nachher gehen bekommen sie
dann eine ganze palette
und das ist nicht diese situation in der
wir uns nach can denken müssen sondern
es sind wirklich entscheidende position
gehe ich jetzt nach münchen zum
studieren oder gehe ich nach berlin zum
studieren ja sowas oder hygienische
behaupten studium oder beginne ich nicht
ein studium so was zum beispiel oder
soll ich philosophie studieren oder soll
ich es nicht studien so wenig
philosophie studiert dann folgen daraus
bestimmte weitere konsequenzen wenn ich
es nicht tue
natürlich auch und irgendwie habe ich in
mir so eine spannende gespräche
das spannende für cains gedankengang
dass es alternativen sind wie ich
irgendwie beide oder zumindest in
manchen genauso das heißt genau es gibt
gründe die für das eine und das andere
sprechen genauso gleich meine freundin
sie nach bremen nach berlin
aber ich will natürlich mit meiner
freundin zusammen
also man also ich will zu holen ich will
aber auch gutes beispiel aber genau
genommen würde ich sogar sagen die
tatsache dass man nur zwei alternativen
hat wenn wir die situation bremer fazit
betrachten impliziert schon dass wir vor
beide gründe haben also dass wir
überhaupt so eine situation kommen dass
entweder oder nun a oder a oder b ist
und bis nach essen und b appliziert
schon als lebenswelt das eben für beide
gründe eine rolle spielen das war vorbei
dass seine gründe haben und dass die
sich eigentlich ziemlich genau der waage
halten
dass wir überhaupt in diese alternativ
situation gekommen sind genau also wir
haben wir haben gründe sowohl den zu
ziehen erst wurde das abtreibungen zu
ziehen
wir wollen und welche der beiden
überhaupt genau aber wenn ich jetzt am
ende nicht gegen meine freundin berlin
studenten dann ist es so ich wollte das
und ich habe ja auch gute gründe dafür
es ist nicht einfach nur etwas rein
zufällig wie bei münster fußball-bundes
wurf gibt es keine gründe für kopf oder
zahl beim münzwurf und gibt es
vielleicht auch keinen will in die 1
genau und man kann da wieder so dass
sich anders vorstellen wie zb in der
physik wenn sie zwei kräfte haben zwei
kräfte haben die wir durch pfeile mit
beträgen veranschaulichen und die sind
genau gleich groß die beträge der kräfte
sind gleich groß und die träger sind
genau entgegengesetzt und wenn sie jetzt
hier etwas drin haben einem gegenstand
hier
dann wird der unruhen man wird sich
nicht bewegen er ist als indifferent
wirkt sich nicht und wir können uns auch
eine situation vorstellen woher genau
der groß gleiche gegenstand ist und er
genau derselben situation ist aber die
situation ist dennoch eine ganz andere
obwohl wir es von außen eigentlich nicht
sehen können beide male gut der
gegenstand nur einmal ruht er deswegen
weil die kräfte eben genau
entgegengesetzt sind sich aufheben
das aber nicht gleich das jetzt mit
diesem gegenstand wo gar keine kräfte
einsetzen also das würde ich sagen ist
so eine schlechte form von ihnen
determinismus also schlecht dass man ein
sternchen das ist eine problematische
form von in der termin ist muss und das
hier ist das was kann sich vorstellen
also wir haben hier bestimmungen
letztendlich die ansätzen an unseren
bildern letztendlich könnte auch sagen
dass der wille der wähler hat zwei
kräfte die auf ihn einwirken und die
kräfte sind genau entgegengesetzt und
deswegen brot der will und bewegt sich
nicht die eine oder andere richtung und
hier dass es wären will gar nichts ist
einfach purer zufall ist und ich weiß
nicht was
die schwierigkeit vielleicht wird es
auch so ein bisschen deutlicher
richtiges leben bis natürlich meine also
liegt es an meiner anliegen dieser 1000
hören er stellt sich das dann irgendwie
so vor dass das einmal so ein chaos
theorie durch bedingungen in unserem
hirn eigentlich dann entschieden wird
bedingungen wie aber vielleicht auch
nicht in unserer gewalt
das müssen wir so ein bisschen offen
lassen es kommt da kommt der gestoppt
im weiteren zu stellen also was man auf
jeden fall sagen kann ist folgendes in
dem jetzt hier diese spannung entsteht
also ganz wichtig glaube ich ist die
spannung auch wenn jetzt spannung
natürlich eine metapher ist oder
zumindest kein logischer begriff ist
dieser spannung also spannung ist also
könnte sagen auch seine energiegeladene
zustand sondern aufgeladen zustand also
wer in so einer situation ist entweder
dass er das und für beide sprechen
gründe
der ist nicht in different dass der
punkt der ist nicht in different ja dass
der punkt also ich glaube da wird es
ganz ganz deutlich wenn wir von
existenziellen optionen stehen dann sind
wir in dieser situation alles andere als
indifferent obwohl wir eigentlich
indifferenz sind weil sie die kräfte
aufheben aber wenn wir es aus einer
phänomenalen sicht beschreiben sind wir
sehr angespannt das ist eine höchsten
form der bestimmtheit eigentlich nur ist
es eine besondere form der bestimmtheit
nehmen die bestimmtheit die sich eben
aufhebt letztendlich aber diese
aufhebungs zustand durch diese spannung
die gleichgerichteten motive der bewirkt
eben einen neuen zustand könnte man
sagen der vielleicht reagiert wie auch
immer in dem dann blöd sich neue dinge
möglichst und über diesen zustand geht
es eben jetzt über diesen
spannungszustand also höchste form von
anspannung eigentlich ist
und in meiner welt tricks bei dieser
ganzen sache ist durch diesen tatbestand
gibt es keine hinreichende ursache für
eine oder andere attraktive oder keine
hinreichenden grund es gibt eben gründe
für die einheit der liebe nach berlin zu
ziehen für alle eltern die nachprimiz
ihn aber keiner dieser gründe ist im
himmel
sonst gäbe es keine spannung und wie so
ein bisschen meine zweifel könnte man
vielleicht dann ein argument um familien
zu sagen man gut in einer situation der
spannung gibt es ja dann am ende der
wenig sparen aufgelöst wird immer so
einen ausschlaggebenden kommt kein
hinreichender grund aber einen
ausschlaggebenden kommt wo der mensch
vergeben die ursache bei ihm sind dann
vielleicht er außerdem die ursachen im 4
und für mich wäre dann die frage also
ich würde das allgemein sofort wenn das
situation des spannung und diese
spannung durch einen ausschlaggebenden
grund ausgelöst wird
der soll die entscheidung fügt dann
müssen wir damit verantwortet und
entscheidungen sind verantwortlich sein
die ausstattung ist und es scheint mir
da nicht gegeben zusammen genommen
dann würde das problem noch mal neu
auftreten obwohl er tief das problem
vermeidet es gibt keinen bereich der
ursache egal welcher welt wir können
danach sagen wir wollten es und werden
gute gründe dafür aber trotzdem ist die
frage können wir wirklich dann
verantwortlich wenn man es im moment so
formen und wir sagen
spannende frage und wir wollen jetzt
einfach mal weiter lesen wie er jetzt
diesen angespannten zustand jetzt weiter
analysiert zeigt er voll ist wie du die
zeit an das touch kann die chance auf
ein sergent ihr layout com ist noch die
thermen resort pressing in germany and
yet it can be world international wolle
terry lee the way to the fact that ins
excel von informationen die agence
privat bei konflikten modus also wenn
wir uns auf basis dieser bedingungen der
ungewissheit entscheiden ist das
ergebnis nicht bestimmt wegen der
vorhergehenden unbestimmtheit sagte ja
und doch kann es sie gewollt werden
das ist wohl der punkt also wir das
zeigt dass das ergebnis aus einer
solchen spannungen die auf lösungen die
ein oder andere richtung
die ist nach ihm nicht bestimmt weil aus
einer unbestimmtheit nicht bestimmtheit
folgen kann
offensichtlich aber wir kommen
letztendlich doch zu einer auflösung sag
jetzt mal die andere richtung
das will aber jetzt nicht bestimmtheit
nicht verantwortlich gewesen so die
integrität von made in germany made of
computing reasons und motive bay lower
dir das denn bei dies iding und
weiterstadt justice in die german is not
an die anderen meinen rationalität so in
germany sind of need not anderem ein
control and responsibility
der würde jetzt sagen das
ausschlaggebende oder so wenn man diese
schließen 500 der ausstattung den
gebunden ist die entscheidung was die
spannung auflösen und damit natürlich
bin ich verantwortlich für meine
entscheidung
das würde jetzt wahrscheinlich dass man
sagen und habe mich anfragen aber vorher
kommt ist es den personen nicht so
auskennen und da gibt er als er denkt
sich offensichtlich ist so wir sind in
diesem indifferenz zustand diesem
gespannten zustand und aus dem heraus
entscheiden wir uns dann ja dann folgen
ja wo kommt der grund der entscheidung
her dafür wären nicht aus diesem zustand
kommen kann
und dann kann man sich fragen kommt er
nicht doch von außerhalb von sowas extra
extrem faktor mäßigen dieses zweite tag
für mich auch noch wichtig was er da
sagt also in determinismus schließt
nicht realität aus und will endlichkeit
und in der termin ist muss auch nicht
kontrolle und verantwortung
ja
ist zum beispiel auch eine widerständige
kräfte geben
bleibt
das kann
das ist ja keine narben durch diese
weise
ja also das ventil einer ecke das wäre
dann vielleicht wenn es einen kompromiss
ja so was könnte man sagen dass man sagt
also wir haben jetzt hier so'n
indifferenz zustand zum kreativen wie so
ein gewitter stell dir vor wie so eine
gespannte gewitter atmosphäre
da braut sich was zusammen spannung und
plötzlich kommt der witz und der zustand
wird aufgelöst und der zustand kann nur
aufgelöst wäre nicht eine oder andere
richtung
oder kann man jetzt den grund gar nicht
mehr so richtig vielleicht angeben
das wäre es probleme will ja eben kost
haben und er will ja auch control haben
das ist so ein bisschen das problem aber
vom bild her kann ich es verstehen wir
haben seine spannung und es entlädt sich
in die eine richtung halten da muss man
fragen warum eben die einrichtung
[Musik]
ja ja ich meine einen punkt dafür wäre
dass man könnte sagen
wie auch immer es jetzt aus schlägt der
blitz ich will es auf jeden fall will
ich ich will es ne ich wollte beides und
ich wäre jetzt sich die münze und ist
der punkt noch wichtiger punkt ich wäre
er könnte auch sagen ich habe die
spannung und ich werde die münze und die
münze löst die münze hebt die spannung
auf und löst die spannung in die eine
oder andere richtung auf und so können
wir uns nicht vorstellen weil die münze
wäre sozusagen etwas was nicht mit dem
spannungszustand verbunden wäre also
diese ausschlag sage jetzt mal oder
blitzschlag der müsste erfolgen aus
diesem spannungszustand selbst heraus
dann wäre es kein externer faktor der
blitz ist fundiert im gewitter dem steht
allerdings ein bisschen entgegen dass er
eben hier im zweiten tat sagt dass man
hier noch kontrolle und
verantwortlichkeit kontrolle jedenfalls
darüber hat wir sind sehr starker
begriff kontrolle
ich habe es in der hand und das ist eben
bei diesem modell des blitzes nicht mehr
da obwohl das ergebnis so war das eben
jemand sagen könnte gut wenn der
ausschlag aus dem spannungszustand kommt
aus meiner innersten angespanntheit im
sinne dieser auch kreativität
meinetwegen dann bin ich damit zufrieden
es kam aus mir selbst und dann muss ich
nicht mehr fragen warum jetzt links oder
rechts ist halt so aufgelöst worden
[Musik]
okay okay
ja ja
ich stimme darin völlig zu bei der kunst
jedenfalls dass er bei der kunst sagen
kann wenn man künstlerische freiheit
einsetzt hat es nichts mit konto
kontrolliert unkontrolliertem agieren zu
tun sondern wir schaffen eine basis die
es sehr kontrolliert wir schaffen diesen
spannungszustand mit viel mühe und
arbeiten darauf hin dass wir überhaupt
so eine situation bekommen der höchsten
spannung und dann lassen wir sie
auflösen aber das war ein letzter punkt
so zu sagen wo es aufgelöst wenn und
darauf haben wir hingearbeitet auf
diesen punkt und dann akzeptieren wir
diese auflösung weil die auflösung dann
die künstlerische freiheit in besonders
reiner form ist die künstlerische
freiheit kommt aber nicht aus heiterem
himmel
so müssen daher ziemlich viel vorher
schon investieren damit überhaupt sein
spannungszustand kommt der wie ein blitz
sich entladen kann überlegen sie mal wie
viele gewitter energie sich
zusammenbrauen muss damit überhaupt ein
blitz zustande kommt das ist ganz viel
energie da verdichtet ist das ist nicht
einfach aus heiterem himmel kommt zu
stande sein blitz kommt zustande dass
ich da wirklich etwas an gebraut
zusammengebraut hat aber dem würde eben
hier dieses zitat also in der
künstlerischen freiheit würde ihrem
total recht geben aber in dieser
hinsicht übertragen auf die freiheit die
auch mit moralischer verantwortung eben
zusammenhängen und das ist ja
künstlerische freiheit nicht bei ethik
und ästhetik ms in künstlerischen also
ethik und ästhetik klar getrennt werden
müssen normalerweise er möchte aber hier
wurde auch eine ethische dimension mit
reinbringen weswegen er die kontrolle
braucht
das heißt ihr modell künstlerisch würde
sich sehr gut auf jeden fall anwenden
lassen
da hätte man gar nicht dieses problem
was du jetzt hier namhaft gemacht hast
woher kommt jetzt die entscheidung dass
wir im künstlerischen modell nicht
notwendig danach zu fragen
und es wäre kohärent wie menschen also
wenn ihr sehen dass bis dahin könnte man
das sehr gute ästhetische theorie draus
machen wenn aber die ethische dimension
mit rein kommt also die frage nach warum
und schuldzuweisung dann kommen wir
riesenprobleme plötzlichen schweren
funktionen also sagen wir jemand dass in
dieser spannung sondern seinen nachbarn
requiem im dom gilt wird zur
verantwortung gezogen
und er sagt eben naja teilnehmer dieser
spannung unentschieden
und dann gab es eben einkaufsprozesse
mein gehirn wer dazu geführt hat dass
diese spannungen dieser die zum
ausgestanden und ich bin mental
ordentlich viel ist über den kaufprozess
dann gehöre ich habe darauf keinen
einfluss
altermedia auch nicht verantwortlich
dafür dass die der spannungszustand
suche nicht so ausgestalten des wehres
verteidigungs argument des mörders und
eigentlich gibt es sehe ich eigentlich
zwei auswege aus dem argument wiederum
sagt reyes verantwortlich für dieses
prozesses sein
aber das ist sehr schwer weil
verkaufsprozess zeichnet sich dadurch
aus dass minimale randbedingungen zu
großen veränderungen
das wird den späteren oder über sagt der
muss für diesen ausschuss leben im
grünen verantwortlich sein
ich glaube das würde vielleicht kennen
sagt kennen würde sagen na ja also er
wollte es doch und der hat der gute
gründe dar begründet da für diesen mord
zu begehen und der beutel ist mobbing
also ziemlich zur verantwortung auch
wenn er nichts davon kam dass jetzt
diese spannungs prozesse so
ausgeschlagen ist nicht so ich denke das
kann wahrscheinlich so würde oder
rechner ist das schwierig sagte ich dass
es nicht drüber nachgedacht aber was wir
auf also guter punkt avance festhalten
müssen ist wirklich hier in
determinismus wie er ihn versteht ist
nicht beliebigkeit ist nicht sondern
reiner zufall chaos und das höchste
konzentration
wenn wir sie sich selbst mal vorstellen
in einer existentiellen situationen wo
sie die alternative b haben und sie sind
zerrissen vor diese alternative
dann ist das nicht gleichgültigkeit so
ein läppischer in determinismus das ist
ein energiegeladener in die therme
wissen muss wo in dieser innen gehen im
energiegeladen haid steckt eben mit
potenzial schon mal drin wo also wo sich
was entwickeln könnte die frage ist nur
wie lassen wir es dann aus schlagen was
ist dieser krieg dieses dieser letztes
hebelchen wir müssen ja eigentlich nur
ein ganz kleines heblich in umlegen oder
im kern muss nur das ganz minimales
passieren um die entscheidung
herbeizuführen
minute
jede möglichkeit worden dass ich mich
bisher unbekannte das eigentlich war
gut dann müsste man ihn für den irrtum
auch zur verantwortung ziehen also an
und wird schon ist ja im falle des
mordes nicht so als könnte natürlich
sein ich habe ihn verwechselt
ich habe ihn vor wichtigsten ist ja okay
gut
ja aber dann wollte ich halt jemand
anderes um bringen also dass das zieht
nicht aber was eben sein könnte ist ja
ich dachte es geht begründet diese
person umzubringen wenn sie die frage ob
es überhaupt gründe geben kann als gute
gründe geben kann aber angenommen
irgendwelche gründe und dann können
diese gründe auf einer falschen
faktenlage passieren zum beispiel ich
dachte diese personen verdiente es
umgebracht zu werden aber meine
recherchen hätten ergeben wenn ich
gründlicher nachgeforscht hätte dass es
gar keinen grund gibt weil sie gar nicht
das gemacht hat was ich ihr
unterstellung deswegen ich sehe jetzt
töten möchte und dann kann man natürlich
sagen ja gut erstes mal würde des
gerichts sagen also selbst wenn sie das
getan hätte gibt es keinen grund ziehen
deswegen zu töten und hält außerdem
hättest du genau recherchieren müssen
und sehen müssen dass es die faktenlage
und ich es also hättest können hättest
können du hast nicht genug mühe
aufgewendet um zu recherchieren
nach kansas sind bestimmte aussage
zurücknehmen wo wir unseren charakter sf
wir unsere entscheidungen von sie auch
sehr schöne dem workshop ausgekommen und
meistens ist es so nachteil man von
ihnen sagen dass wir mit meisten
situationen liegt unser charakter
zusammen wenn es den umgebungsschutz
ohne jemanden eindeutig fest wie wir
dorthin kommen wir gleich entspannung
situation hätte wäre das nur weil wir
unseren charakter schon ziemlich fest
genau haben und genau und er hat ein
beispiel das auf das er sich bezieht das
ist eine geschäftsfrau die ganz eigen
der eile ist und also zu einem
vorstellungstermin muss und auf den weg
gibt es eine bedürftige person so ein
bisschen wieder barmherzige samariter
ist ein bisschen halt noch ein bisschen
mehr angespannt weil sie musste dem
meeting jetzt wenn sie zu den medien
nicht bekommen kommt kriegt sie den job
nicht und da gibt es aber an bedürftige
personen die dann noch auf dem weg und
dann ist in dieser konfliktsituation
gibt moralische gründe die dafür
sprechen dass meeting sausen zu lassen
und die krankenwagen zu rufen
und es gibt aber persönliche interessen
oder finanzielle oder wie auch immer
interessen die dafür sprechen die person
jetzt einfach liegen zu lassen und zum
meeting zu gehen und das ist so eine
existenzielle situation man sieht ich
muss eigentlich zum meeting davon hängt
meine weitere karriere ab oder mein
weiteres leben vielleicht sogar und auf
der anderen seite sagt mir mein gewissen
oder meine moralische erziehung oder
meine moralische werte system sagt mir
da musst du jetzt aber helfen und so
eine situation schnell dass ich jetzt
vor
da kommen als immer moralische gründe
bin spiel
fragen wollen
gemeint ist
trotzdem kommt rein
aber das heißt nicht dass
die habe ich auch sagen
und auch die täter stellen
verkaufsprozess unterbrechen
haben sie
fehlen sollten
seit 30
auf gesellschaftlichen
ja aber letztendlich trotz dieser
situiert haid würde ja keynes sagen sind
wir dafür verantwortlich auch wenn wir
jetzt diesen genau aber es ist nicht
auch im luftleeren raum völlig richtig
es ist immer situiert und jetzt bringt
er hier also nochmal zwei
charakterisierung dieses beispiels
erster solist united mit den konflikt im
modus also das ist das was du gesagt
willens spaltung und dann weiteres
zitaten das ist glaube ich auch ganz
wichtig das ist bezogen auf diese
geschäftsfrau dieses geschäfts vor
beispiel die in die termine stick neue
switches providing artikel zwei helfer
kommen temptation s not coming from
other sources but is coming from hell on
wheels and supply es tut weh aber sie
besitzt das ist der punkt
diese dieses hindernis also es geht
jetzt eine inderin deterministischen
störgeräusche sowas rauschen oder so in
diesem zustand und der in diese in die
termin ist zustand der ist erstmal
hindernis für die entscheidung wenn bei
dem gründe ich mich gleichermaßen in
clean ihren dann ist da nicht nichts
sondern ist eben dieser spannungszustand
denen sie jetzt in deterministischen ich
weiß nicht neues lernen oder geräuschen
kann oder rauschen vielleicht in die
tennis taschen und das charakterisiert
sie als ein hindernis als erstmal hinter
nicht also steht entsteht was neues aus
diesem spannungszustand
ok jetzt sagt sie fern ist und jetzt
kommt hier jetzt kommt hier dieses die
auflösung ist dieses dieses zustands
aufgelöst
der konflikt im mutterschutz dies auch
komplexe networks auf interconnections
in the brain circulating impuls ist in
der feedback lobs mit generali entwurf
in hailer cognitive pause processing wie
in port of one of his newly networks
konsistenten women's reasons for
excellent stopping the victim ambitious
modifying anti aging to network connect
x2 der termin ist neues wird es im
obstacle tour herren making of one of
the choice is coming from hell desire to
make die ada und weißwasser
die indo german racing for attention
creating the background neues produced
by just as the news of the making of
pink ist racing neues one can say that
you're dead and are responsible for one
can say that this as well as the one ist
josef hohmann succeed in raging river
kam die absage informiert
was kann man daraus ziehen
jetzt bezieht sie diesen zustand der
indifferenz auf das gehirn auf die
netzwerkstrukturen des kerns und wie
verstehst du dieses rauschen oder dieses
neues bringt schon sehr war neben super
gehören dann würden wir sagen etwas was
ein etwas größeres
wenn wir da etwas tun der ton des waldes
wollten dass aufgrund unseres eigenen
weg und aufgrund der gründe die uns dazu
veranlasst haben diesen sich zuvor mit
und es ist halt daneben immer so dass
dieser bilde unseren eigenen leben
überwindet das finde ich es hilfreich
was hat der einzige zweifel oder wie es
ist wenn das wird letztlich keine
kontrolle darüber haben welche dabei
gewinnt die frage ist auch nicht
überzeugen also auch diese rede von
gewinnen
das wirkt so als seien da zwei agenten
in mir also zwischen kündigt aus zwei
instanzen die da miteinander kämpfen und
das ist das ist ein problem aber es ist
ja mein gehirn also ich bin praktisch
zwei weil es ja in meinem gehirn ist bin
ich immer noch
aber man hat den eindruck dass es so
eine starke einheit sein mussten
einheitlich instanz die sich ganz
bewusst entscheiden
obwohl komme wo kommt dieses nicht dann
her genau kommt dieses ich dann von
außen dann muss dieses ich aus diesem
spannungszustand heraus erklären und
nicht von außen und erlegt das ganze
dann irgendwie die hirnstrukturen als er
will ja kein extra faktor annehmen also
bezieht das mal aufs gehirn wald im
gehirn gibt es ja nix äußerliches ja
also es gibt ja so eine eine schwelle
eine activa zions aktivierungs schwelle
überwunden werden muss da diese schwelle
und das tapsige dieses hindernis das
muss einfach überwunden wird und wer
überwindet das wie kann dieses hindernis
überwunden werden die man letztendlich
kommt dann wieder das problem dass ich
mein erlöst jetzt erst mal dass inter
termin ist problem bisschen auf indem
man sagt es gibt ein spannungszustand
aber wenn man dann im spannungszustand
ganz genau hinschaut hat man eben wieder
diese kleine schwelle wo man dann eben
sich entscheiden muss man könnte wieder
sagen gut dann zu mich wieder näher hin
dann habe ich wieder so ein
spannungszustand aber letztendlich wenn
es um die überwindung geht ist es wieder
seit dieses ganz kleines hebelchen aber
dass hebel muss umgelegt werden es kann
doch so klein sein
es müssen heblich jetzt sein und
irgendjemand muss diese hebel umlegen
und es muss umgelegt werden von
niemandem weiter notwendig walter
something ist dann unter kontrolle
ja das ist jetzt wieder dieses argument
also wenn jetzt mal eine entscheidung
getroffen wurde
das ist jemand wie sie entschieden wird
ist eher die frage wenn sie mal
entschieden wurde
dann können wir sagen natürlich wenn wir
jetzt hier in dieser zeit diese richtung
hier auflösen dann werden eben die
gründe geltend gemacht sondern hier ist
berlin
hier ist bremen da spricht die freundin
dafür na also private sondern
persönliche private umstände und wenn
wir jetzt also das ganze hier nach
bremen jetzt immer auflösen lassen dann
fällt das weg hier haben wir nur das und
dann sind natürlich die motive liegen
auf der hand klar die gründe die eben
die andere waagschale gelegt wurden die
überwiegend
aber wie kommen wir da hin zu dass eben
das zünglein an der waage jetzt eben
dahin ausstreckt
aber wenn wir das ergebnis haben also
wenn wir von der entscheidung her das
ganze betrachten dann haben wir
natürlich die ganzen gründe da die hier
diesen kraft vector konstituiert
die bauern müssen nach berlin nach
bremen gefahren also was mit krone schon
solche filme sind zufällig und aber
wollte und gründe auch natürlich reasons
nur also auch und da konntest du hattest
du was du zu deiner kontrolle das deine
spannung ist an spannung situation sich
so auflösen dass noch leben könnte zum
beispiel oder er könnte zum beispiel
sagen ja es war in meinem gehirn und sie
sofern es sich in meinem gehirn so
abgespielt hat war es etwas was zu mir
gehört jedenfalls kann oder könnte
vielleicht sagen das gehirn zu
kontrollieren ist ein paradoxes
formulierung das ist ein widerspruch in
sich
weil das was im gehirn ein gutes stimmt
nicht ganz
nicht alles was ich im gehirn tod
unterliegt meiner kontrolle ipso und das
stimmt ja nicht kennen ja dinge vorgehen
die den tumor oder so war es auch oder
sowas
das ist unterlegt natürlich nicht meiner
kontrolle aber er könnte sagen wenn es
jetzt mit freiheit zu tun hat dann ist
eigentlich die frage überflüssig ob es
in meiner kontrolle weil es war ja mein
gehirn sagen nein nicht pathologisches
gehirn mein gesundes gehirn bei dem sich
das getan hat und das nenne ich jetzt
einfach mal kontrolle
ich weiß nicht das wäre ein falscher
begriff von kontrolle offensichtlich
oder
wird dieser schalter hat dieser schalter
der hebel umgelegt wird dann das das
zünglein an der waage das wäre irgendwie
da war dann alles könnt ihr sagen ja
aber könnte sagen dass ich es eben mein
gehirn vielleicht also das ist halt
dieses umlegen und da brauche ich nicht
mehr weiter zu fragen das soll aber das
wäre halt nicht unser budget von
kontrolle
letztendlich ist intuitiv ist zu sagen
das ist etwas was ich tue oder was nicht
kontrollieren unterschied zu dass so
etwas in mir geschieht sowie die
die blutzirkulation also darauf habe ich
irgendwie nicht so direkt also das ist
ja etwas was ich vollzieht und das ist
etwas was mir geschieht
und so scheint mir auch diese neuronalen
prozesse auf dem ersten blick zu sein es
sei denn ich kann darüber nochmal
verfügen aber dann braucht er doch wie
das weiß ich ja da ist so eine meldung
das hätte der die heimlichen der
die uns nicht immer unter verändert und
musste absagen
zum beispiel
ebenfalls kontrollieren
[Musik]
ja
werde ich alles unter kontrolle hätte
eigentlich angst entscheiden
nein
naja also
[Musik]
also normalerweise würde man sagen dass
wenn also das wird er kann also wir alle
motiviert sein asyl versuchen mit
eigenen waffen zu schlagen zwischen
schwierig zu zeigen also die eigene
mache ist mir genau also den werde das
problem ist angeles hängig welche
verantwortlich sind für etwas dann
müssen wir auch verantwortlich sein für
alle die gleichen gewinnt sagen
der mörder hat jemand umgebracht ist
eröffnet verantwortlich nachdem gute
wahl wirklich verantwortung ist in allen
bereichen und ursache wenn wir sagen
seine entscheidung zusammen mit den
umständen ist eine hinreichende ursache
für den mord dann muss also zumindest
teilweise nach kellner stefanie zeit für
entscheidungen stimmt also wenn er nicht
für seine scheinbar sind müssen wir für
die umstellung also der fall
die entscheidung von entscheidungen
leben wir eigentlich
er spricht ja gar nicht soviel von wales
kommt die interessanterweise gar nicht
vor so häufig als er betrachtet das
ganze von der entscheidung her kommend
also wenn ich mich jetzt entschieden
haben wenn jetzt spricht von resourcing
wenn jetzt das ganze die spannung
aufgelöst ist in eine oder andere
richtung
dann so redet ihr dann bin ich darin
frei willentlich dann habe ich die
ganzen gründe aber wir müssen uns fragen
wie kommt das denn zu dieser
entscheidung
wie kommt es denn zu der wahl und da
sagt das sehr wenig dazu schon zu dieser
kritischen situation
und hier spricht er jetzt von einem
parallelen prozessor also das gehirn sei
so eine art parallel prozessor und jo
ganz unten sagt ein cases und jetzt
kommt damit die begriffe in case of cell
formation sf agence aus simultaneously
trying to use of pure and computing
cognitive tasks basf zum 1
also das ist ihr problem haben wir hier
kleine akteure in unserem gehirn so
linke hälfte also kreativität verso-s
rationalität links wäre das recht so und
rechts bis links
er sagt nein wir sind die person in
denen sich die parallelen prozessen
abspielen
die multitasking wir versuchen beides zu
machen während das heißt am ende sind
wir immer der gewinner aber auch der
verleger weil wir durch
hier bringt er doch mal am schluss des
beispiels dieser business frau er sagt
die antwort ist so sind vom rathaus
business women who wants to go back to
the victim ist sam ambitious woman who
wants to go to hell s angels toren
innside by divisions auf cookies and
what she wants to be enough und i'm
total
das ist bekannt auf komplexe information
solutions will von den tieren
internationale note bei exzellentem
estate zu mein problem ist hier diese
sache wenn sie sexy wenn ja aber wann
und wie genau wenn es der fall ist dass
sie sich da auflöst und die einrichtung
dann ist das natürlich alles durch
gründe bestimmt und so weiter aber wie
kommt denn genau zu diesem ausschlag für
das ein oder andere das passiert
irgendwie doch so einfach in ihr mann
könnte man sagen ja da ist das ganze
problem des schlechten in determinismus
wieder aufgeworfen
also erscheint das ganze immer von
hinten herr zu sehen
mensch also immer wenn das schon
passiert ist ja dann ist das so zu
erklären klar wie kommt es denn dazu
eine möglichkeit wäre
wir können sagen okay streng genommen
ist man dann in so einem fall dass der
mörder nicht verantwortlich
aber es zumindest dafür verantwortlich
dass er es überhaupt in erwägung gezogen
hat den mord zu machen also dass er
überhaupt in diese spannung situation
reingekommen heißt wir haben immer noch
genug genügend grund ihm vorhaltungen
sogar ganz
wie kann es sein dass du so was
überhaupt dass sowas will ich überhaupt
in frage kommt wie kann es sein dass
überhaupt eine situation rein also das
wäre eine möglichkeit ich glaube so weit
würde er nicht gehen das wäre eine
möglichkeit für ihn so weit kann man
glauben schenken so viel verantwortung
hier und hier noch mal ein zitat die
wahl ins spiel kommt hier sagt er
also sehr von jazz an die thermen but
not und kostbar caused by the agency
fans die die business wo man strengt
sich da an die kämpft zwei motive und
irgendwann löst sich auf und der grund
ihre freiheit ist der kampf letztendlich
mit den motiven die anstrengungen aber
die anstrengung ist halt nicht gericht
auf das einer dass anträge auf diesen
blitz der sich da entlädt dann könnte
man vielleicht sagen
vielleicht haben noch ein kurzes aber
das ist jedenfalls so das wichtigste was
hier ist als hier sagt du noch was im
binger hinrunde realization of summer
von purposes in die therme ist ein
paradox city opens up the jam the
possibility of truth or in other way
since world war denn ergänzte terry und
riesenslalom in lienz creators of
ourselves to the free world must be at
times in life beyond traces in auch
wills wissen wie macht overcome
ja aber wie überwinden wirst nie genau
dass wir es irgendwann überwinden ist
klar aber er scheint mir immer vom
ergebnis her auszugehen
von der folge und wie genau damit
das ist der fall der offen ist jetzt
bringt die experiment als ist sagt das
ist sagt er sagt es im art experiment
okay ich glaube zimmer hier schon gut
und das ist am schluss vielleicht noch
also als fazit my account of review als
national und logical entities
relations.de batterien accounts of free
agency du nord sony das postulat
applications dieses intentions and like
and creation factions paris also keine
zusätzlichen unter logischen entitäten
erscheint und logisch sparsam zu sein
aber offen bleibt dann doch die frage wo
und durch wen dieses kleine hebel
umgelegt wird wodurch es dann zu dieser
auflösung kommen er scheint wirklich
immer vom ende her das ganze zu sehen
und damit eigentlich die eigentliche
frage wie es denn stimme kontrolle kommt
nicht zu erklären oder das eine letzte
meldung
ja aber wir kommen eben aus dem
widerstand selbst nicht zu einer der
beiden auflösung da muss noch was
zusätzlich dazu kommen und das ja schon
es ist eine notwendige bedingung aber
was das notwendige zum hinreichend macht
das scheint er hier jetzt nicht richtig
plausibel machen zu können
wir diskutieren darüber in der nächsten
sitzung weiter lesen sie sich noch mal
diesen text gründlich durch den nächsten
sitzung was machen wir dann noch mal
kennen oder aristoteles dann beginnen
wir nicht im historischen teil als wir
nutzen die nächste sitzung noch einmal
abschließend um so ein paar fragen noch
zu klären vielleicht noch ein paar
probleme bei robot game und dann
beginnen die zweite hälfte des semesters
oder unseres seminars in der wir dann
von ganz früh beginnen mit aristoteles
anfang und uns dann hocharbeiten bis
immanuel kant glaub ich dann bis zur
nächsten sitzung